Je l'ai écrit, je m'appelle Jordan et dans mon
discours d'aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler un
peu de moi maintenant, je suis sûr que beaucoup d'entre vous
se demandent ce qu'un
enfant irlandais fait sur scène et bien je vais
essayer  répondre à cette question pour vous je
vais vous parler un peu de mon histoire un
peu de ce que je fais certains de mes projets
je parle juste de moi mais d'abord je vais juste
vous donner une petite introduction donc j'ai 16
ans  vieux, je viens de Waterford, une
petite ville d'Irlande connue pour nos
petits pains et notre cristal, c'est
donc ma ville ouais, je suis un
programmeur autodidacte, je programme depuis l'
âge de neuf ans et ouais je '  je
suis à peu près un enfant normal aussi et mais pourquoi suis-
je un programmeur pourquoi pourquoi dois-je faire ce que je fais
bien pour répondre à cette question nous
allons devoir revenir en arrière un peu j'ai dû
revenir à l'époque où j'étais juste un peu  gamin
j'étais à peu près un enfant normal la plupart
du temps je jouais à des jeux vidéo comme mes
amis j'ai joué beaucoup de soutien comme
mes amis mais je n'ai toujours pas  ced il y
avait quelque chose de différent et en quelque sorte
me séparait de tout le monde,
par exemple, je vendais mon ancien type
de jouets à des gens que je vendais
des leçons de Marshall à mes amis même
si je n'avais aucune idée de ce qu'était l'art martial
alors et je  à peu près eu ce
genre de coup pour gérer mes propres entreprises,
j'avais à peu près cet
état d'esprit entrepreneurial et, fondamentalement, je voulais juste
créer ma propre entreprise, mais le
problème était que je n'avais vraiment
rien pour faire profiter une entreprise comme moi
Je ne connaissais rien au karaté, je
ne voulais pas vendre de jouets, j'ai donc dû
trouver quelque chose pour lequel j'étais bon, si
vite que quelques années plus tard, j'ai eu un grand
intérêt pour le jeu sur Internet
appelé Club Penguin, qui est à peu près
ce jeu où vous aimez jouer à un pingouin
et aimez parler à des gens comme jouer à
différents jeux avec vos amis,
c'est donc un concept intéressant,
mais fondamentalement, certains des
utilisateurs qui ont joué pour le pingouin ont créé leur
propre type de sites Web et b  journaux sur le
jeu et en gros, je pensais juste que ce
serait une sorte d'intérêt amusant ou un
passe-temps amusant, alors un jour, ma grand-mère
m'a acheté un livre sur la programmation, j'ai commencé à
regarder des vidéos sur YouTube, j'ai commencé à
lire différents sites Web à peu près
juste comment faire  créer mon propre mon
propre blog, donc finalement je l'ai fait.
l'ordinateur sur l'
ordinateur alors j'ai fait accrocher mon club sur le
site Web et après quelques années
j'étais à la recherche d'un nouveau défi
alors j'ai fait un peu de recherche et j'ai trouvé
le kit de développement iphone qui est à peu
près ce qu'Apple  utilisé pour donner en quelque sorte aux
développeurs l'accès pour créer leurs propres
applications et jeux iPhone et c'est donc à
peu près ce que je voulais faire, alors j'ai
regardé un peu à ce sujet et j'ai réalisé
que pour ceux qui veulent créer des applications iPhone,
vous devez avoir un  pomme mac et
fo  r ceux qui ne connaissent pas les macs apple
surtout pour moi un très cher donc
j'avais besoin d'un peu d'aide si je
voulais en acheter un alors un jour je suis allé
chez mes parents je leur ai à peu près dit
comme allez-vous m'acheter  ce mac et mes
parents qui n'avaient pas vraiment la moindre idée de
ce que je voulais faire pensaient que je voulais
jouer à des jeux plutôt que de créer le mien alors
ils ont dit non ouais alors je suis allé essayer
quelques méthodes différentes, je leur ai demandé sans
cesse de les embêter ils  j'ai toujours dit non, donc
finalement j'ai dû aller au dernier
recours qui était avec la fraude et donc
un jour j'ai falsifié une lettre d'un
dirigeant d'Apple prétendant être ce grand
homme d'affaires comme le PDG d'Apple
n'aime pas Steve Jobs ou quelque chose et  Je l'
envoie à mes parents et j'explique en quelque sorte
les avantages d'acheter un
mac et comme ça ceux-ci auraient pour
moi si heureusement mes parents l'ont cru et
ils m'ont acheté un mac
Merci ouais alors maintenant j'avais mon mac et
maintenant je sorte de  commencé à en apprendre un peu plus
sur la façon dont nous pourrions aimer faire le vôtre
L'application iPhone et des choses comme ça ont commencé à
tester avec un peu de jeu
jusqu'à ce que j'aie quelque chose d'un
produit fini, le jeu s'appelait alien boy
versus humans et à peu près c'était
comme cette version mobile d'envahisseurs de l'espace
comme faire comme un roi alors comme
ce sont des images vraiment très mauvaises que
j'ai dessinées sur l'ordinateur et je les
ai toutes mises comme si j'avais créé le jeu que j'ai
lancé sur l'App Store au départ pour
moi j'ai vu cela comme une sorte de projet expérimental
comme je ne m'attendais pas à faire  de l'
argent ou quelque chose comme ça,
mais heureusement pour moi, le jeu est en
quelque sorte à la hauteur comme sur l'App Store
et comme s'il était numéro un dans les
charts en Irlande et au Royaume-Uni dans une tonne d'
autres pays différents et qui  était
vraiment bon parce que j'en ai gagné un peu d'
argent et cela m'a fait
penser que si je pouvais gagner de l'argent en
créant mes propres jeux, alors peut-être que je pourrais le
voir comme une sorte d'entreprise commercialement viable
et peut-être que je pourrais voir que c'est
comme  ce que je pourrais  j'utilise mon esprit d'entreprise
pour et j'ai donc fait un peu de
recherche et regardé quelques vidéos et à
peu près créé ma propre entreprise à partir de
là, qui était ma première ma première
entreprise, alors j'ai appelé les jeux KC,
j'ai essentiellement lancé un certain nombre de
différents plus  les jeux iphone ont
une variété différente et ils sont là-haut
assez réussis, donc c'était
kc games qui était ma première entreprise et
passer à ma prochaine entreprise, j'ai pris un
chemin complètement différent du
jeu, donc l'idée de mon prochain projet
est venue quand je  était à l'école donc un jour
j'étais en classe avec mon costume ma classe
mon professeur et en gros elle avait ce
genre de gros livre noir qu'il utilisait pour
garder toutes les informations sur une école
comme à portée de main dans les
informations sur les résultats des examens juste des informations générales  et
fondamentalement, je ne sais pas comment, mais elle a
réussi à perdre ce livre et à peu
près perdu toutes les informations que je pense que
c'était l'un de mes amis qui l'a volé pour lui,
elle a à peu près perdu ou toutes les
informations  chez elle, elle avait gardé
comme tous les étudiants toute l'année
et j'ai donc eu l'idée de créer à peu
près un moyen plus sûr et plus
efficace de gérer tout cela et j'ai donc créé
une application appelée enseigner où
c'était à peu près un  système de gestion basé sur le cloud
pour qu'elle puisse aimer les informations du contrôleur
sur l'ordinateur et les gérer sur le
club, alors oui, ça s'est plutôt bien passé comme si
j'avais ça comme 10 000 utilisateurs principalement
basés en Afrique du Sud et en Inde, donc je
gérais ça depuis ma petite maison  et j'ai
appris et donc il y avait un petit
problème avec ça, mais à cause du
fuseau horaire, je devais rester
éveillé toute la nuit, comme traiter avec
différents clients et des choses comme ça,
alors quand je suis allé à l'école le lendemain
et c'était  comme vraiment fatigué donc
malheureusement j'ai dû abandonner le
professeur pour eux ouais alors maintenant je suis sur
mon prochain projet c'est encore une fois c'est un
peu différent de ce que j'ai fait
avant cela combine à peu près mes
intérêts pour le jeu et l'éducation
toge  Au cours des dernières années, en
faisant différentes conférences et en apprenant simplement
ce que je veux faire, j'ai guidé cette
énorme passion pour l'éducation et en
particulier comme l'éducation technologique
parce que je pense que la programmation est un
outil vraiment vraiment vraiment cool qui peut être utilisé
par n'importe qui pour la création comme les affaires pour
tout, mais malheureusement, les enfants
de mon pays et de nombreux autres pays
n'ont pas la possibilité d'en
savoir plus et donc je pense que c'est un gros
problème, donc j'ai voulu créer une
application qui combine un spawn
environnement multijoueur avec un
langage de programmation visuel qui peut à peu
près apprendre aux enfants à coder pendant qu'ils
jouent à un jeu avec vos amis, donc le
jeu s'appellera un manteau pour enfants et,
fondamentalement, comme les enfants pourraient créer, ils sont
comme un petit personnage similaire à
Club Penguin comme  faire le tour de ce monde,
mais en même temps créer leurs propres
jeux et aimer faire avec leurs amis,
ils pourraient donc apprendre les
bases de p  programmer, ils apprendraient également des
compétences collaboratives, des compétences de travail d'équipe
, mais travailler ensemble et aussi
des compétences créatives qui pourraient être vraiment
bénéfiques pour l'avenir, car même
avoir les compétences de programmation les plus élémentaires
pourrait être vraiment très
bénéfique si vous voulez un emploi à l'
avenir et  donc c'est le code de la porte, donc à peu
près, certaines des
entreprises sur lesquelles j'ai travaillé dans le passé,
mais j'ai aussi d'autres intérêts comme je suis
un enfant aussi, donc comme j'ai beaucoup d'
intérêts, j'aime vraiment le sport et en
particulier je  J'adore jouer au football, donc
quelque chose que j'aime vraiment faire est de
combiner mon intérêt pour les affaires et la
technologie avec mon intérêt pour le football
.
cette année, donc en gros, j'étais
à une conférence à Madrid, j'y
parlais et après la conférence, j'ai en quelque sorte
fait une interview avec le réseau de télévision espagnol à
peu près comme tout comme
di  Je ne m'attendais pas à
ce que quelque chose se produise mais j'ai reçu un e
-mail le lendemain du système de
Florentino Perez qui est président du
Real Madrid, donc j'ai à peu près vu
mon interview à la télévision, je m'étais
intéressé et  en moi et m'a invité à être un
invité présidentiel à un match du Real Madrid
qui était assez surréaliste et
donc je suis allé à Madrid, j'ai pu me rencontrer
Florentino, j'ai pu aimer aller à un grand
match de Madrid, j'ai pu rencontrer des joueurs
comme Cristiano Ronaldo comme Garibay comme
Benz et j'ai rencontré le mur
donc c'était plutôt cool et c'est juste un
exemple de la façon dont je combine mon
entreprise et mes autres intérêts que
j'ai vraiment de la chance de pouvoir faire ouais
donc je  J'ai aussi travaillé plusieurs fois avec l'
Union européenne
pour donner le point de vue d'un jeune
sur son agenda numérique ouais, je ne sais pas,
j'ai fait quelques choses sympas avec
ce que j'ai pu faire  et juste
comme finir comme juste vous dire un peu
sur comme quoi  c'est comme être
beaucoup plus méchant comme évidemment il y a
beaucoup d'avantages à ce que je fais mais
en même temps il peut y avoir des
inconvénients à ce que vous êtes donc par
exemple un avantage c'est que cela a été mentionné
plus tôt mais comme dans dix ans  Je serai
comme ça 26 nous avons déjà 13 14
ans d'expérience de travail dans l'
industrie, ce qui est évidemment plutôt cool
ah et c'est vraiment bénéfique aussi
c'est aussi comme si c'était cool pour moi à un
jeune âge, nous devons obtenir un arc  pour mes
produits, mais à cause de moi, à cause de moi,
beaucoup d'
organisations médiatiques aiment m'interviewer
et me parler, ce qui me donne l'
occasion d'aimer la publicité de mes jeux
sur mes applications, ce qui est toujours bon et
j'ai aussi l'occasion d'aimer  aller dans des
endroits incroyables et j'aime la viande
des contacts vraiment sympas qui pourraient me profiter à
l'avenir comme j'ai mentionné le Real Madrid
mais je parle aussi beaucoup à travers
le monde j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller
à l'état quelques fois  comme dans
Dans  dia qui a été une expérience vraiment cool
et c'était génial l'Arabie Saoudite d'accord cette
année donc c'était plutôt cool
j'ai été vraiment chanceux à cet égard
aussi mais en même temps je
rencontre des contacts vraiment cool qui pourraient
aimer de l'aide  moi à l'avenir, comme je l'ai dit,
ils peuvent aussi avoir des inconvénients,
par exemple,
je dois travailler à temps plein parce que je dois aimer aller
à l'école et je dois aussi aimer être un enfant,
ce qui peut parfois être difficile à gérer
et ce que je pense et gérer
cela est vraiment important d'avoir
et d'avoir une sorte de
structure d'organisation, donc comme je vais à l'école
normalement, puis après l'école, je travaille dans
une entreprise pendant un petit moment, puis
le week-end ou prends juste un  rompre avec
tout juste être un enfant vraiment et ouais
un désavantage d'honneur que j'ai trouvé
que pour des enfants comme moi, il est parfois
difficile d'être pris au sérieux quand on travaille
dans l'industrie comme dans le passé, ils ont
essayé d'aller vers des investisseurs différents
ment  ous essaient d'embaucher du personnel, mais parce qu'à
cause de mon âge, cela a été une limite
pour moi, comme les investisseurs ne voient pas vraiment
comme une opportunité viable d'investir dans un
enfant comme moi, je suis à peu près comme
ils disent oh c'est vraiment cool  idée que
vous avez à cause de votre âge, nous n'aimons pas
croire des choses comme ça et donc
il y a quelques difficultés à cela, mais
je pense que cela change parce que de plus
en plus d'enfants montrent à quel point ils peuvent
être créatifs et aiment créer comme des produits vraiment cool les
gens vont  commencer réalisé avec
le bon support et les bons outils
comme les enfants peuvent faire beaucoup plus comme
Mark Zuckerberg a créé Facebook quand il
avait 19 ans dans cette salle de collège, donc comme
ça c'est assez important, je pense
que plus d'histoires comme ça pourraient
montrer mais les enfants  peut réellement faire et juste
avant de finir, je vais donner un
peu de la voix qui a comme premier
est de ne jamais abandonner comme j'ai eu dans le
passé une tonne d'obstacles différents comme
si c'était quelque chose de petit  comme un  bug
sur mon jeu ou quelque chose de gros comme quelqu'un qui
vole mon idée en gagnant de l'argent
mais parce que j'étais motivé pour
continuer et mais parce que j'étais
motivé pour continuer et j'étais
passionné par ce que je faisais j'ai
réussi à obtenir beaucoup de  bon en dehors de ça,
donc s'il y a un conseil que je peux
lui donner pour ne jamais abandonner une autre
voix importante et triste, c'est d'obtenir un
réseau de soutien comme mes parents étaient mon
réseau de soutien avec le soutien de mes parents
juste financièrement mais comme moralement et
comme étant donné un  beaucoup de temps je ne
serais pas là où je suis aujourd'hui, donc s'il y a
un autre conseil que je peux donner, c'est
vraiment amusant de soutenir le réseau pourrait
être des amis la famille je pense que je pense que c'est
vraiment important et oui merci
beaucoup pour l'écoute c'est  mon histoire
merci